[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin Ihnen allen einen schönen
guten Abend Norbert ist bei mir noch
etwas hast du für uns heute Fußball
Champions League und eine winterliche
Goldmedaille schönen guten Abend auch
von mir ausführlich dann also später und
so sieht unser Überblick heute aus
Deutschland und der Krieg zum Jahrestag
der russischen Ukraine Invasion erklärt
Kanzler Scholz im ZDF-Interview was aus
der Zeitenwende geworden ist
Verben für den Frieden vor der
unfallversammlung bittet Außenministerin
baerbock alle Mitgliedsländer um ihr
Jahr zu einer neuen ukraine-resolution
und sie kann es kaum fassen Katharina
Althaus gewinnt bei der Nordischen
Ski-WM von der normalen Schanze die
Goldmedaille
[Musik]
morgen jährt sich Russlands Überfall auf
die Ukraine ein Krieg der unsere
sicherheits- und Energiepolitik
dramatisch verändert und die Wirtschaft
stark belastet ein Krieg der Sorgen und
Ängste schürt und von dem niemand genau
sagen kann wie und wann er endet schon
vor diesem Jahrestag positionieren sich
die mächtigsten Politiker der Welt und
so auch Bundeskanzler Scholz vor zwei
Stunden im ZDF Interview Andreas Huppert
und Lars bodensack Berichten der
Bundeskanzler exklusiv im ZDF bei
Maybrit Illner am Vorabend des
Jahrestages des russischen Überfalls auf
die Ukraine verteidigt Olaf Scholz sein
oft kritisierten Kurs eher zurückhalten
und abwägen zu handeln vor allem bei
Waffenlieferungen die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger unseres Landes können sich darauf
verlassen dass ich mich nicht kenne
machen lassen werde von all den vielen
Interviews von den öffentlichen Aufrufen
von den Erklärung sondern dass es gut
vorbereitet wohl abgestimmte sowohl
abgewogene Entscheidung bleiben das ist
in einer solchen Situation etwas dass
man von einem Regierungschef erwarten
hat ob Raketenabwehrsysteme oder
Kampfpanzer ob bei der Aufnahme von
Flüchtlingen oder humanitärer Hilfe
selbstbewusst verweist Scholz auf den
deutschen Beitrag für die Ukraine
deutschland muss sich an dieser Stelle
von niemandem Vorwürfe anhören denn wir
sind diejenigen die sehr sehr viel
machen und das eben auch mehr als viele
viele andere gegen ein schnelles
Kriegsende stehe das aggressive Vorgehen
Putins das mache es momentan der Ukraine
unmöglich über Friedensverhandlungen
nachzudenken so Scholz das ist eine
meiner größten Sorgen dass das jetzt ein
sehr lange sich hinziehen der Krieg wird
mit unglaublichen Zerstörung und
Verlusten auch nach einem Jahr Krieg in
der Ukraine der Kanzler sichert den
Menschen in dem angegriffenen Land noch
einmal zu sie so lange zu unterstützen
wie es notwendig ist moralisch
wirtschaftlich aber auch militärisch
damit und das ganze Kanzlei Interview
gibt zwei Maybrit Illner heute Abend ab
viertel nach zehn oder wenn Sie wollen
schon jetzt in unserer ZDF heute App
in New York will die UN-Vollversammlung
noch heute über eine resolut Resolution
abstimmen die Frieden und den Abzug der
russischen Truppen aus der Ukraine
fordert es gehe bei der Abstimmung um
die Zukunft aller so Außenministerin
baerbock jeder müsste sich jetzt
entscheiden ob er isoliert an der Seite
des Unterdrückers stehen Wolle oder auf
der Seite des Friedens Deutschland hatte
den Resolutionsentwurf zusammen mit
anderen Staaten vorgelegt in den
nächsten Stunden soll abgestimmt werden
Johannes Hano in New York könnte es eine
klare Mehrheit für die Resolution geben
also wir haben gerade eben mit Annalena
baerbock gesprochen und sie hat uns
gesagt sie soll ja auf den letzten
Drücker noch mal hierher gekommen um so
viele Staaten wie möglich davon zu
überzeugen dieser Resolution zuzustimmen
die einen Friedensplan vorsieht auf den
Prinzipien der Kater der Vereinten
Nation bislang sind diese Resolution
hier ja mit sehr sehr großer Mehrheit
abgestellt worden ja meine sehr große
Mehrheit bekommen aber es hat sich etwas
getan in der letzten Zeit vor allen
Dingen die Staaten aus dem globalen
Süden sind es leid dass ich alles um die
Ukraine dreht man möchte einen schnellen
schnellen Frieden und in diese Lücke
stoßen jetzt sozusagen Russen Chinesen
und auch die weiß Rosen wurden hier
amendments vorgetragen also
Zusatzartikel die vorsehen dass dieser
Revolution nur dann zugestimmt werden
kann wenn es ein Ende der
Waffenlieferung gibt und zwar sofort und
wenn die Interessen aller Kriegsparteien
berücksichtigt werden da hieß es hier
von den Unterstützern der Ukraine das
sein vergiftete Vorschläge denn ein zwei
klar wenn die Ukraine so weit ist die
Außenministerin formuliert wenn die
Ukraine aufgibt gibt es keine Ukraine
mehr wenn Russland den Krieg aufhört
zumindest keinen Krieg mehr und da muss
man jetzt sehen wie in drei Stunden hier
abgestimmt wird interessant ist auch wie
China sich entscheidet china hat sich im
Moment mehr auf die Seite Russlands
gestellt und wir warten drauf ob China
erstmals in dieser ganzen Abstimmung mit
Russland stimmt alles was unter 143
stimmen wäre wäre eine große Erfolg für
Russland danke schön nach New York
Johannes Hano
weiterhin verstärkt die russische Armee
im Osten der Ukraine ihre Truppen an
mehreren Frontabschnitten der britische
Geheimdienst rechnet mit neuen Angriffen
auch in der Regierung von dort sind es
keine 50 km bis zur russischen Grenze
unsere Reporterin Katrin Eigendorf war
bei den ukrainischen Truppen an der
Front
ein Labyrinth von Schützengräben
durchzieht die Landschaft wir sind an
der Grenzlinie zu Russland die
ukrainischen Soldaten wollen nicht lange
auf dem freien Feld stehen gerade erst
am Morgen wurden sie beschossen nur
einen Kilometer von hier entfernt stehen
die Russen ich folge ihnen hinunter zu
ihrem überwachungsposten von hier aus
überblicken Sie das Gebiet
die Russen sind da hinter diesen Hügeln
das ist die staatliche Grenzlinie der
Ukraine
im September haben sie die russischen
Soldaten aus den umliegenden Dörfern
vertrieben jetzt sollen sie hier die
Grenze sichern um einen russischen
Vorstoß aufzuhalten haben sie nur
Maschinengewehre sie alle sind
Zivilisten und haben sich freiwillig
gemeldet um zu kämpfen
die Soldaten sind ziemlich nervös im
Zusammenhang mit dem Jahrestag des
Kriegsbeginns rechnen Sie hier mit
verstärkten Angriffen auf ihre Stellung
alleine heute hat die russische Armee
mehrfach auf ihre Stellung gefeuert weil
die Sicht gut ist ist das Risiko
besonders hoch dass die Angriffe
weitergehen deshalb sollen wir uns nicht
zu lange hier aufhalten nur aus der
Krieg dauert nun schon ein Jahr
welche Perspektive sehen
Sieg nur Sieg wir müssen den Feind über
die Grenzlinien zurücktreiben wann das
ist ich weiß es nicht es hängt von den
Entscheidungen unserer Führung ab oder
der Hilfe des Westens die brauchen wir
um uns zu schützen
obwohl es nicht in ihrer Hand liegt die
Einheit von Russland ist entschlossen zu
kämpfen egal wie lange der Krieg noch
dauert
die Angst vor dem aggressiven Nachbarn
Russland ist in den baltischen Staaten
überall zu greifen besonders in Litauen
im Westen grenzt das Land an die
russische Exklave Kaliningrad und im
Südosten an Russlands Verbündeten
Belarus was das für die Menschen in
Litauen bedeutet und wie sie hier Alltag
durch den russischen Einmarsch in die
Ukraine verändert hat zeigt uns Svenja
bergauf
nicht weit von der Hauptstadt Vilnius
verläuft die Grenze zu Belarus sie wird
vom litauischen Grenzschutz scharf
bewacht mit Kameras Patrouillen und
Zäunen in Begleitung der Grenzschützer
dürfen wir uns dort umsehen seit
vergangenem Jahr schottet Litauen seine
EU-Außengrenzen mit so einem vier Meter
hohen Zaun ab das ist aber nicht das
einzige mit dem Litauen aufrüstet es
werden zum Beispiel auch mehrfach
Raketenwerfer aus us-herstellung
bestellt die Zusammenarbeit mit der EU
und NATO wird intensiviert und das alles
um einen Einmarsch Russland wie in die
Ukraine für das eigene Land
unwahrscheinlicher zu machen in Vilnius
sollen ukrainische Flaggen und
friedensbotschaften die Straßen
eindeutig wird hier gezeigt auf welcher
Seite man steht durch die geographische
Nähe zu Russland und Belarus können sich
die Litauer gut in die Lage der Ukraine
versetzen
es ist eine sehr beunruhigende Situation
weil unser Nachbar so unberechenbar ist
in Litauen nichts passiert dass NATO
Russland abschreckt und ich hoffe die
Ukraine wird bald Siegen
das Gefühl von Russland bedroht zu
werden ist hier in Litauen auch
historisch nichts Neues
wir erleben eine Art DejaVu wenn wir
sehen was die Russen in der Ukraine
machen die Geschichten unserer
Großeltern aus Litauens Zeit in der
Sowjetunion werden auf einmal sehr real
life mit dem russischen Angriff auf die
Ukraine hat auch in Litauen eine neue
Zeit begonnen in der die Gesellschaft
zusammenwächst Solidarität mit der
Ukraine zeigt und Klarstellung bezieht
gegen Russland und seinen Verbündeten
Belarus
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Habeck will es
für Unternehmen schwerer machen die
Sanktionen gegen Russland zu umgehen er
geht davon aus dass über Drittländer
viele Produkte letztlich nach Russland
gelangen ziel sei es des gemeinsam mit
anderen EU-Ländern zu verhindern dabei
ist gerade heute ein weiteres
Sanktionspaket der EU gegen Russland
zunächst gescheitert und das Florian
neuhahn in Brüssel führt zu
naheliegenden Frage warum und was
passiert jetzt
na wir kennen das mittlerweile von den
letzten sanktions Paketen auf den
letzten Metern knirscht es immer
gewaltig und so auch diesmal da ist es
eher ein Nischenthema dass wir Streit
sorgt nämlich der Import von
synthetischen Kautschuk den man künftig
verbieten möchte aus Russland und da
stellen sich hier zwei Länder quer die
nicht die typischen Quertreiber sind
nämlich Italien und Deutschland beide
verlangen längere Übergangsfristen für
die eigenen Konzerne wollen die eigenen
Industrie Schützen zu lang sagen andere
wiederum jetzt also wenn man morgen
einen neuen Versuch starten aber jetzt
bereits ist klar frei nach der Herberger
nach dem sanktions Paket ist vor dem
sanktions Paket es werden also weitere
kommen und das wichtigste Thema dann sei
sagen Diplomaten die Umgehung von
Sanktionen zu stoppen das gelingt in der
Tat Russland relativ gut mit Hilfe von
anderen Ländern wird wieder Türkei z.B
und das sagen die wichtigste Aufgabe für
alle Pakete die jetzt noch folgen wir
werden berichten vielen Dank Florian
jetzt in den Nahen Osten nach dem
gestern bei einem israelischen
Militäreinsatz und einem anschließenden
Feuergefecht investjordanland mindestens
11 Palästinenser getötet wurden hat sich
die Situation weiter verschärft aus dem
Gazastreifen heraus feuerten in der
Nacht militante Palästinenser Raketen
auf Israel kurz darauf griff die
israelische Luftwaffe mehrere Ziele im
Palästinenser Gebiet an getroffen wurden
laut Armeeangaben eine Waffenfabrik und
ein Militärgelände
der Mord an Walter Lübcke erschütterte
die Republik und noch immer versucht ein
Untersuchungsausschuss des Hessischen
Landtags diesen Fall aufzuarbeiten im
Sommer 2019 wurde der Kassler
Regierungspräsident von dem inzwischen
Verurteilten Rechtsextremisten Stefan
Ernst erschossen der Täter war dem
Verfassungsschutz bekannt stand aber
nicht mehr unter besonderer Beobachtung
wie es dazu kommen konnte soll der
Ausschuss klären heute wurden die
letzten Zeugen dazu gehört Peter Wagner
zieht jetzt Bilanz
2000 Aktenordner durchgearbeitet
zweieinhalb Jahre lang dutzende Zeugen
angehört zuletzt heute den amtierenden
Innenminister Peter Beuth und auch Ex
ministerpräsident Bouffier der bis 2010
Innenminister war die zentrale Frage gab
es viele bei den hessischen Behörden und
warum war Lübkes Mörder ein Neonazi mit
dicker Strafakte er wurde ebenfalls vom
Ausschuss befragt nicht mehr im Visier
von Polizei und Verfassungsschutz
es gab jede Menge Versäumnisse im
Landesamt für Verfassungsschutz Hinweise
wurden nicht richtig zugeordnet Hinweise
wurden nicht verschlagwortet es war ein
Fehler dass er unter dieses vereinfachte
Verfahren fehlt und eben nicht weiter in
der Bearbeitung war sprich vom Landesamt
beobachtet wurde der Mörder von Walter
Lübcke war 2009 noch als brandgefährlich
eingestuft worden vom selben hessischen
Verfassungsschutz der in der nach aus
den Augen verlor seine Akte sperrte laut
Innenminister Beute ein klarer Fehler
und Parlamentarier stellten eine
katastrophale Kommunikationsstruktur
zwischen Polizei und Verfassungsschutz
fest ich hätten wir heute eher gewünscht
dass Herr Beuth auch mal das Wort Demut
in den Mund nimmt und sagt ja auch ich
habe eine politische Verantwortung die
geht es nämlich letztlich hat er leider
nicht getan die ganz große Frage
sicherlich die auch im Raum steht ob
dieser schreckliche Mord hätte
verhindert werden können wird schwierig
oder vielleicht auch nie zu beantworten
sein eines aber wurde auch deutlich
Strukturen und Prozesse bei den
hessischen Sicherheitsbehörden wurden
grundlegende erneuert die Fehler sollen
sich nicht wiederholen
in die Tarifverhandlungen für den
öffentlichen Dienst kommt offenbar
Bewegung um zehneinhalb Prozent mehr
Gehalt fordern die Gewerkschaften sollte
es in dieser zweiten Verhandlungsrunde
keine Einigung geben drohen weitere
Warnstreiks Innenministerin Phaser hat
jetzt ein erstes Angebot der Arbeitgeber
vorgelegt und Einzelheiten dazu von
Katrin Lindner
ihre Arbeitsplätze sind heute unbesetzt
geblieben bei der Kfz-Zulassung beim
Straßenverkehrsamt oder in den Kitas
Warnstreik im Norden Brandenburgs in
Prenzlau die Gewerkschaft verdi hat rund
1500 Beschäftigte der Kreisverwaltung
Uckermark und der Stadtverwaltungen
Prenzlau und Schwedt zum ganztägigen
Streik aufgerufen
ich gehöre zu der niedriglohngruppe und
wir brauchen einfach mehr Geld
ganz klar und deutlich um alle die
Lebenskosten aufdecken zu können ganz
wichtig geht nicht mehr anders wir
müssen jetzt fordern und dafür auch
gerade stehen und einstehen die
Forderungen lauten 10,5% mehr Gehalt
mindestens 500 Euro für Azubis und
Praktikanten 200 Euro mehr ein erstes
Angebot liegt vor Erhöhung der Entgelte
um 5%, eine Steuer- und abgabenfreie
Einmalzahlung von 2500 Euro und 5% mehr
ausbildungsentgelt unser Angebot steht
der Ball liegt nun im Feld der
Gewerkschaften wir sind weiterhin bereit
zu verhandeln und ich hoffe dass wir ein
gutes Ergebnis gemeinsam erzielen können
die verweigern ein Mindestbetrag sie
verweigern eine soziale Komponente
Gewerkschaft und Beamten und lehnen das
Angebot ab wird heute keine Einigung
mehr erzielt wollen die Gewerkschaften
ihren Arbeitskampf verstärken mit
Streiks die dritte Verhandlungsrunde ist
für Ende März geplant
jetzt zur nordischen Ski-WM nach
Planitzer und Norbert zur ersten
WM-Medaille ja goldene Skispringen
Katharina Althaus feiert ihren fünften
Weltmeistertitel und ihr erstes Gold in
einem Einzelwettbewerb heute von der
Normalschanze ein spannender enger
titelwettkampf den die Oberstdorferin
für sich entscheiden konnte
Katharina Althaus konnte ihr Glück am
Ende kaum fassen nach ihrem ersten
Sprung lag sie noch auf dem zweiten
Platz und so musste sie im zweiten
Durchgang als vorletzte springen mit
einem Satz auf 97 Meter hatte sie auf
jeden Fall schon silbersicher und so
musste der Sprung der führende
Norwegerin Anna odiniströhren die
Entscheidung bringen ihre Weite ließ sie
hinter Althaus unter Österreicherin Eva
pinkelnig noch auf den Bronze Rang
zurückfallen
ich habe natürlich gezittert nicht das
erste Mal weil deine WM aber das erste
Mal dass es sich für mich ausgegangen
ausgegangen ist Gold für Katharina
Althaus und ein hervorragender vierter
Platz für die wm-debütantin Celina
Freitag
gestern Abend Fußball Champions League
das Achtelfinal Hinspiel Leipzig gegen
ManCity ein hart umkämpftes Remy
Manchester in Halbzeit eins klar besser
aber nur mit einem Treffer Halbzeit 2
die Leipziger mutig druckvoll das eins
zu eins am Ende hoch verdient
für das Unentschieden sorgt der beste
Mann auf dem Platz Leipzigs
Innenverteidiger Josko Quartal das
leichte aufstützen nur eine Randnotiz
beim perfekten Kopfball RB belohnt sich
für eine couragierte zweite Spielhälfte
wir sind noch im Spiel wir haben jetzt
ein Rückspiel und wir haben paar Tage
Zeit uns zu schütteln viele Dinge
mitzunehmen aus dem Spiel und dann nicht
mehr so eine erste Halbzeit zu spielen
wie heute die war mutlos ideenlos dazu
fehlerhaft wie hier von Xaver Schlager
das 0:1 durch Mares City 45 Minuten lang
klar überlegen mit mehr als 70% Ball
besetzt was Leipzig Mut macht die
Reaktion nach der Pause viel aggressiver
plötzlich Tor gefährlich ebenbürtig und
damit hoffnungsvoll für das Rückspiel in
knapp drei Wochen
ja und dann muss Manchester in muss
Manchester muss Leipzig in Manchester
gewinnen und ins Viertelfinale ein das
wird schwer genug danke Norbert David
Bowie kreative Ausnahmekünstler bekommt
ein neues Zuhause zumindest seinen Erbe
sieben Jahren nach seinem Tod wird ihm
zu Ehren ein Museum eingerichtet mit
dabei mehr als 80.000 Kostüme Briefe
Fotos und handgeschriebene Songtexte bis
Fans einen kreativen Schaffensprozess
bewundern können dauert es allerdings
noch ein bisschen ab 2025 soll das David
Bowie Zentrum in London seine Pforten
öffnen
[Musik]
zum Wetter neuer Regen ist unterwegs
dazu gleich mehr von öestentherly das
heute journal um 21 Uhr 45 Marietta
Slomka meldet sich vor dem Jahrestag des
Überfalls auf die Ukraine direkt aus
Kiew morgen an dieser Stelle Barbara
halweg so viel von uns danke und auf
bald
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter der Regen in der
Nacht der wird sich allmählich ostwärts
verabschieden aber es bleibt nicht lange
trocken denn von Norden her kommen schon
wieder neue Wolken ins Land und mit
Regen der dann morgen in den
Mittelgebirgen vor allem dann in Schnee
übergeht dahinter folgt kühlere Luft ja
und in der Nacht also Regen der
allmählich weniger wird und nach
ostenden abzieht dann bleibt es nicht
lange trocken denn von Norden her kommen
neue Wolken rein und die bringen schon
Regen ganz im Süden da ist es nämlich
bei tiefsten Temperaturen dort bei null
Grad z.B 6 Grad Richtung Rhein-Main
Gebiet und morgen an viele Wolken
weiterhin von Norden her und der Regen
zieht Richtung Mittelgebirge und geht
oberhalb von 400 m in Schnee überall es
kann aber auch mal einige Schneeflocken
bei kräftigen schauen bis ins Flachland
geben aber nicht schnell Schneedecke
wird sich nicht ausbilden die
Temperaturen ja höchste Werte von zwei
bis als 13 Grad noch einmal semmelt im
Süden Deutschlands die nächsten Tage
weitere Schneefälle vor allem den
östlichen Mittelgebirgen und einem
Alpenrand und ab Sonntag dann spürbar
Kühler damit ein schöner Abend